with the news at Fox broke last night
about the true extent of China's
coronavirus cover-up
we at the Ingraham angle felt obligated
to tell you well we told you so China's
ambitions have never been a secret yet
over the years our political media
financial in yes our health experts have
claimed it was in your best interest to
cozy up to the Communist Party well why
well so they could make a quick buck and
flood our country with cheap imported
goods much to the detriment of American
workers well given how devastating this
entire Kovan 19 pandemic it's proven to
be well I thought it was important to
remind you of those who ignored this
global danger and dismissed it all
together I give you the China threat
deniers first I want to begin three
decades ago when China was struggling
mightily to emerge in the modern world
as the Wall Street Journal's Bob Davis
wrote in 2018 it's difficult to remember
how economically backward the country
was in the early 1990s inflation hit 24%
in 1994 nearly 60% of the population
lived on less than a buck 90 a day but
China had a plan the nation's Communist
Party leaders would rule Western
political and economic elites in order
to gain access to the powerful World
Trade Organization and one of their key
targets was former President Bill
Clinton and therefore raised well they
weren't subtle at all during Clinton's
1996 reelection campaign there were
efforts some successful by senior
government officials in China to funnel
illicit foreign contributions into his
coffers of his campaign well just a few
short years ago and a years later excuse
me Clinton was already trying to
convince Americans that they needed to
welcome China into the global trading
community America has a stake in China's
success in a China that has overcome the
challenges it faces at home a China that
is integrated into the institutions that
promote global norms
Oh World Trade Organization well one
year after that communist pep rally well
and with China's position in the WTO
secured Clinton and Federal Reserve
chair Alan Greenspan held a triumphant
Rose Garden event as China citizens
experienced economic gains so will the
American firms that trade in their
expanding markets China's progress
towards prosperity an accession into the
WTO will create new opportunities for
American businesses and farmers
I believe that chairman Greenspan has
established a pretty good record for
knowing what is in America's economic
interest oh my god I can't even listen
to that well to be fair it wasn't just
the Clinton administration just two
years later george w bush echoed his
predecessors naive sentiments china is
on a rising path and America welcomes
the emergence of a strong and peaceful
and prosperous China work out for us
and then Obama of course echoed Bush
like literally the United States
welcomes the rise of a prosperous
peaceful and stable China we want China
to do well well did this do they share
notes or they passed notes along
computer ticket it is crazy so what did
America get out of China's inclusion
into the WTO well we've lost millions
and millions of manufacturing jobs we
saw our trade deficit balloon
intellectual property ripped off left
and right and meanwhile China broke its
promise to select foreign banks
participate in their you know in all
their business which they undervalued
their currency we know all that they got
huge margins for years and you think
that would upset the titans of Wall
Street like former goldman sachs CEO
Lloyd blanket fine right China's rise
obviously it's important for China but
it's important for everybody in the
world
I think China's leadership has proven
its competence over the last couple
decades well at least blank fine
defended Trump's tariffs last year but
that was after he had left his position
at Goldman where he had a financial
interest in playing nice all these years
later after all the trade abuses all
that intellectual property theft all the
market manipulations the provocations in
the South China Sea what they've
continued to do to terrorize Taiwan the
world World Health Organization's you
would think that the politicians in both
parties especially the ones who will be
their party's standard bearers in 2020
that then they'll be very clear-eyed now
about the China threat we face China is
going to eat our lunch come on man I
mean I you know they're not bad folks
folks but guess what they're not a
competition for us China's not our
problem if we invest and remember who we
are no another problem and I'll look
around Joe look at what's happened to
America over the last four weeks we lost
all of our job gains since the last of
course recession now it's time for China
to enter the forefront of the American
political conversation and if you see
someone denying what China has done to
America our workers are people now our
health with the way they handled this
virus ask yourself what's in it for them
you can usually find the answer pretty
quickly